south african president cyril ramaphosa
has
reimposed a ban on alcohol sales and
ordered the closure of all bars as part
of new restrictions
to contain a resurgence of the
coronavirus including a new variant
he also announced an extension of the
nighttime curfew from
9 pm until 6 a.m ramaposa
said reckless behavior contributed to
the recent spike and is putting wreck
putting pressure on hospital emergency
units he said the new restrictions would
be reviewed in a few weeks time
for more now we're joined from cape town
by dw correspondent adrian kriesch
adrian fill us in on just how severe
the pandemic is in south africa right
now
we're currently in kailicha at a
hospital that's the biggest township
here in
cape town and just one health worker
told us the house is on fire that is
how bad it is or how bad it has been
over the past weeks because the numbers
have been steadily
increasing we don't know by what amount
at the moment because testing hasn't
been done properly throughout the
festive
season most likely the next days we will
see the extents but
the wars is also still yet to come
because during the christmas festivities
traveling was allowed people were
allowed to have private meetings
with their friends and family and many
epidemiologists and also health workers
here are fearing that
this will mean a further increase of
cases in the next
two to three weeks and possible the next
peak that will be coming then but people
here the health workers are quite
relieved about the measures that were
imposed by the president yesterday one
in particular
the ban of alcohol because they hope
that this will decrease the number of
other cases coming here
to the hospital remember this is the
third alcohol ban we've seen in south
africa
during the first two beds we have seen
it clearly that the number of trauma
admissions
went drastically down and that is also
the target here now that these numbers
will go down so the health workers have
time
to focus on covert related issues a new
variant of the coronavirus has been
detected in south africa tell us more
about that
we still know quite little about the new
variant what we do know
is uh first research research suggests
that it's more contagious um
and that it has been spreading rapidly
in hot spots areas here it means that
it's already the dominant
variant that is uh persistent in south
africa at the moment
but still a lot of more research needs
to be done but what is clear now the
second wave is definitely here
that's what epidemiologists say and you
can also feel it from friends and family
there are more and more cases that you
hear about i talked to a friend recently
he got covered three weeks ago because
he went to a barbecue with 12 friends
11 of them got the virus after the bbq
so this is another anecdotal evidence
for the more contagious variants but
as i said more research needs to be done
to fully understand what is happening
and also to see if it's really more
deadly because at the moment
it doesn't seem to be that case how well
prepared is the health care system there
adrian to deal with this new surge
it's going to be definitely a challenge
because we're already seeing now that
not enough preparation
was done between the first wave and the
second wave that we're experiencing
now there are already cases not here in
cape town but outside cape town and some
hot spot areas that
hospitals are full especially icu
beds are not available anymore patients
have to be transferred and
this is what they are expecting here in
cape town as well in the next week that
there will be
a challenge in finding icu bets and that
will mean for health workers they have
to prioritize they have to make
decisions who will get an icu bet who
will get on oxygen
for example this might be the scenario
but again
we still don't know what's really
happening also during the first wave
remember in south africa
everybody thought it's going to be very
bad in the end it wasn't that bad so
there's still some sense of optimism but
what we have to understand here in the
end is also that this thing here will
take quite some time
south africa will not get a massive
amount of vaccines next year the
president announced in the first quarter
on the second quarter of next year first
arrival of vaccines maybe up to 10
percent of
people here will be able to access it
but definitely not enough to reach hurt
immunity so the country will most likely
face a third
and a fourth wave in the next year
adrian good to see you
uh correspondent adrian kriesch there in
cape town